It Feels So for me so nice to see my mom
help it with Myla it just feels for me
good that somebody wants to caring about
my baby like I want to care about my
baby that I don't need to ask for it
that's what I was wondering honestly
from Mrs Green
my mother what you doing
especially getting along already though
right so she spends like a good three
days with your mom I was thinking maybe
we can have her to babysit out there
there was no Studio
perfect that's what I want to hear we
definitely need a babysitter
do you understand
and she said she doesn't like it because
you cannot return to your home country
for 10 years when you apply for a
refugee oh yeah okay
hi Joey
there's jovia
why why I don't like when you're talking
another language speaking my name all
the time
is that your mom Mojo what's y'all
saying about me
Jovi what why do you keep saying that
learn the language did you say I love
Joey he's the best husband in the world
yes okay
we only been here for a few hours with
my mom and everybody it's making me
honestly want to stay here for a longer
time I it's making me to wanna
this makes me do not want to go back to
USA
I love my life in America but that's why
I'm confused because in the same time I
want to spend time with my family and
friends
so for now I don't know for how long can
understand yet
[Music]